the girag and experience you were on Fox
News yeah once upon a time I made it in
there did it smell like sulfur it's not
like Souls why are the girls that work
there so fucking hot because they know
the higher people burn
that's insane they're way too hot it's
not fair because men will agree with
them just to hope that they will say
yeah high five you'll change your whole
philosophy and there's you can find
clips on YouTube where people just put
together every time they like open their
legs during the half various segments
praise the Lord
they're too hot it's unfair that's like
hypnosis you know some of those what's
that woman's Megan what's her name the
really angry when I get in Cali she's so
fucking the hearts were there goes where
she show me some megan kelly this is uh
this is him this is really cool play
this because this is how I found out
about Lee
but back it up so I'm sure you guys can
have a lot more jokes for the rest of
the campaign here Wow just keep what you
can I can I just ask a questions yeah
sure what what is Fox News it's just a
parade of propaganda and then it's just
add it's just a festival of ignorance
what wait a million people are dead in
Iraq come on this is ridiculous what's
the point of this this is insane your
people at home go outside go go finish
me well love your fake blue you know all
right all the news you can at Fox News
all right thanks is the best what's
there sorry what's the best part we're
also dings didn't pull out Captain Kirk
this morning because it's Saturday
morning we'll have some fun Greg you've
done the cushiest job in the world
yeah look who just uh beamed aboard
right now the ladies from the Starship
Enterprise
hello well
oh I just wrote a new book on Captain
Kirk and the way he was able to woo
beautiful women like this coming up it's
a book about Captain Kirk getting laid
but come on the fictional character
Captain Kirk to by the way yeah not even
William Shaq no no it's a law book I was
in the green room with then I could not
figure out why there were these women
there I had no idea how about that you
just it was almost like it was scripted
because you said that and they showed
you was the most inane stupid piece of
shit I didn't even know that was coming
up next oh my god it was perfect you
couldn't have been what if they went to
some serious news and fucked you yeah he
wanted to you could see in his face as
he read the teleprompter he was like all
right we're gonna get out of this and go
to ah shit indie rock it's like
completely proved your point like right
away I come on Mare how did Kirk get
laid he just gave written wrote that he
got laid the writers made him get laid
he's not a real guy jesus fucking christ
this is an alien's there's two wars
going on the fucking entire banking
system had to be bailed out by taxpayers
money he was running late they just
wanted to see what a human cock was like
that's how he got laid do you think they
have like a bunch of shit that they will
throw out there like beach balls to
distract and they get like they get it
from the CIA every week there's a Star
Trek check they just have to send it to
like this Emily we want you to talk
about this week let's just just zap the
American mind there's a pop really since
yeah yeah no no no no no you know I mean
I don't believe that it is I don't
believe I think I tend to think that
it's more incompetence than it is
conspiracy I think it's ratings they
don't actually care about the news they
only care about ratings they don't care
about the news but I think in general
like even the the most of what we think
of as being this big gigantic conspiracy
with our government and the media is
more incompetence and whorish behavior
than anything just their prostitutes
yeah it prostituted themselves out
because that's where they got the good
assignments they got the good places
they got the big ratings I mean you
don't get to that point you don't get to
that job unless you've proved yourself a
faithful foot soldier to whatever their
message is generally you know they're
not you're not gonna get hired on there
yeah and even guys that used to be kind
of like rebels like Geraldo
era rather Rivera was kind of a rebel at
one point dan yeah you know he was the
guy that had Dick Gregory on TV and
showed the Zapruder film for the first
time wasn't he also the guy got a fist
fight at a KKK rally I think i'ma show
up someone hit him in the head with a
chair they might not even been trying to
hit him it was just a melee and I think
a chair went flying he guy's nose broken
and he was fucked but he was so excited
so excited he had an actual cut at his
face I'm a tough guy Lee was he was
supposed to box Frank Stallone or
something crazy like that too I think a
long time ago oh my god they might have
actually done it I don't know I'm pretty
sure but he's a wild dude at least he
was a while dude you know and now he's
just like Fox News puppet it's weird
when you see the ones that actually
stick to their guns they don't last long
I mean qianqiu lasted two months at
MSNBC before he went before he needed to
leave amber lion is another one that
left because her Bahrain story actually
mention Bahrain CNN she brought it back
to them and said this is what's going on
Bahrain but they were doing ads talking
about how great Bahrain was and they
wouldn't play our segment yeah yeah
she's been on the podcast before and she
explained it all to us since it's so
hard to believe that what we considered
to be like a signing revered institution
of news like CNN has just a bullshit
propaganda wing that they that they're
capable of that kind of behavior if
she's telling the truth I don't know I
wasn't there I assume she is she seems
very honest I don't know anybody else
aside on the other side I don't know
what the fuck's really going on so I
probably shouldn't comment on what CNN
did or didn't do but I know for a fact
they're not reporting a lot of shit
that's going on I'm never putting a lot
of shit and I feel like all these
networks the mainstream media it's a
very small box of accepted thought that
is allowed on them it's not it's not
they're not going to go either very far
today to either side or outside that
boxes no use it's not really the news
and that's one of the more interesting
things about the internet is because the
internet now there's all these sources
that are like more real news like
they're telling you about shit that's
going on that you might not have known
so we getting on Fox News girls why they
so far those girls are so goddamn hot
like I don't want to marry them I don't
wanna have relationships with them but
if I was a single man I would be very
attracted to those angry bitches
or the Weathermen in LA I just think
they're so they're so like aggressive I
don't know if they're so strong like
they're so Stern in their opinions yeah
most of them are not dumb there's
nothing to it dumb no there's something
sexy about those mean bitches yeah just
because I'm a glutton for punishment but
if you um like when you're on that show
like what what is it like when you're in
that studio does it feel weird do you
feel like well that's the thing is like
all of them just seem like they're doing
their job I mean yeah they work for the
evil empire but they don't they're just
like whatever gets him through the day
oh I need to say this thing and this
thing and then we know we wrapped for
the day like so I had to remind myself
why it was important for me to do that I
like reread an article about a million
people died in Iraq I mean this was this
was several years back and and you know
because you don't want to fuck up the
show like yeah I felt like I needed to
do it I only wanted to be on there once
I was like if they were having me on
it's gonna be a one-time thing this is
it dude it was if you were like a
publicity whore and I know you're not
but that would be an awesome move I mean
it works out great I never thought it
was 7:00 a.m. on a Saturday I truly
thought the only people and this is four
or five years ago we're not everything
on the news went online right I truly
thought the only people seeing it would
fox news fans at 7:00 a.m. on a Saturday
and instead it went up online and viral
and all that shit if you got something
relevant to say the internet will catch
it yeah they'll find it and they'll put
it out there to go back to that girl
like standing sitting there with their
legs open this is insane I just want to
point something out of how we are so
weird like as a culture that this is a
part of like normal everyday office life
like we got to make some decisions here
like okay look at this woman she's
showing everything but her vagina
I mean her knee is just strategically
blocking her labia her legs are wide
open and she's hot as fuck now here's
the thing if you put the chyron right in
front of the vagina then everybody would
know the news exactly we'd be a very
informed country and women would get
angry if you knew the news oh you were
looking at a vagina and you read the
fucking news huh
like she look it's just weird that they
get to dress like that like she's
completely wearing cum fuck-me pumps
back that up again let's dissect this
look at her like her shoes those are
like I want to go out and get sex
shoes there's a not comfortable by any
stretch of the imagination they show
most of your foot her almost her entire
legs are exposed you imagine if a guy
was sitting there like that
you know how bizarre that would be if
there was a show where a guy was sitting
there in a tiny tiny kilt and you know
that you could bear if it moves his left
knee an inch to the right you're gonna
see his cock for sure and this and they
also have like an ejection button that
slings them into the stratosphere once
they hit 35 the hidden ager hit an age
limit they disappear aw poor girls
that's fixed she had some kind of
irritation down there so well I think
Sarah Palin brought the dumb milf back
so ha ha ha ha
maybe maybe you'll move in that
direction but I don't think she actually
brought it back she brought it back for
a little bit but now people oh my god
you say too much crazy see GILF GILF
you're forgetting the grin right right
right she's a GILF you don't want to say
that duckies that'll fuck with your dick
that's creepy yeah milf is okay but GILF
not so much it's just weird that we have
these
odd standards of sexual attire in the
workplace and not just in the workplace
but on television like on television
promoting this too strange propaganda
machine and just really hot girls with
their vaginas hanging out yes explosions
and hot girls okay I can't pay attention
whatever the fuck she's saying where
she's your thigh oh my god see if I see
that girl I go wow I wish she liked me
you know especially if you're lonely and
you know you're not married or anything
do that whatever is like 12 times her
size
yeah it's Rob Ford's fat brother and
what other shows has that cameraman it
from the ground up skirt it is Mexico
it's totally an obscure they're panning
from the vagina up
it's off-center just slightly he's
trying to show off his too though you
gotta give him credit he's well you know
he's gotta go to war you know you gotta
get a respect I just he doesn't give a
foot look look the only way I'm gonna
get this one is if I let her know I
don't give a fuck
here's my gut I'm gonna trying to cover
myself up I'm staying an extra straight
I'm spreading my legs wide look at that
package she's going for the don't give a
fuck yeah points he's like I might be a
fat fuck but I'll fuck his shit out of
you dirty bitch I'm fat because I like
to live the good life that's what he's
saying I like how there's playlists
who's that one all the different ones
who's that one the one that you just
that's a fox went to the red end yeah
it's great that one the blonde that was
on screen I know who she is that's the
one she's been on these things before
they're all hot though they're beautiful
it's weird but it's just such a dirty
trick the eye I'm not especially like if
you're married and you know we when
you're trying to be monogamous you're
going to look at sex in a different way
because you look at like a girl that's
like super super hot and you know I
could never get that if you're single
you can have your delusional you'd be
like man if I just ran into her at the
right places time maybe this could
happen so it's a different thing so it's
the there's a wistful almost romantic
way you look at the Fox News girls if
you're married I'm honest on the same
note it's like when I went out when a
hot celebrity you like gets divorced
there's something inside the most looser
of guys it's like now I got a shot you
know like Angelina Jolie gets divorced
and people like okay they think all I
gotta do is to be there I'm just there
guys are so fucking delusional they feel
like all they gotta do is be at the
right place the right time you know
maybe she goes to the car shop because
her wipers broke and she wants try to
fix it herself and you know I get to
impress her by my knowledge of
windshield wipers and she realizes it
I'm just a regular guy and sometimes
girls Jesus Christ look at this she
actually pulled her shirt up look BAM
like Oh Jer you pull it up how dare you
you dirty bitch oh my God look how she
sits it should like go perfect posture
it's kind of like going back to when you
were like really young looking at like
like JC Penney's lingerie catalogs like
way more intense yeah and you wonder why
people who watch Fox News idiots I mean
not that a lot of network time but you
know they did that study that people
that watch Fox News know less about
what's happening the world that people
watching no news at all I believe that I
love that that make sense you know
you're gonna find out about Captain
Kirk's love life so these are two
regular guys ABC look how ABC has
regular girls ABC is more probably
geared towards women that don't want to
be threatened the drugs in the
background you never seen this video no
yeah
is he naked nice hammered in his shorts
well Christine they are the whole
neighborhood knows the boy they jumped
every fucking second-story window fell
that's amazing
oh my god that's funny yeah if you leave
the fucking camera on long enough people
catch the craziest shit ever did you see
any other like this the snowstorm
drugged his son he got jacked
yes yeah I dare say yeah the snowstorms
all throughout the the country they've
been getting these nutty snow and ice
storms yeah
what is that man it's it should be not
as unfair I mean I don't want to say
that pretty girl shouldn't be able to
get a job they certainly should but it
shouldn't be exclusively pretty girls
telling you about important shit we're
too weak
we're not paying attention to the
message no no no but that's thing if you
see an ugly girl on the news you're like
that girl knows her shit
all right she fought her way to the top
this there's something about um like a
like what I said like those Fox News
women that like the one you were talking
about before the show started who argued
with someone about Santa Claus being
white megyn kelly apparently is said
very authoritative Lee that Santa Claus
is white she's very authoritative always
a lot of those gals are but there's
something like for beta men especially
for men they're weak and beaten down by
life
the ultimate fantasy is that this woman
accepts you the ultimate fantasy is that
she's impressed by you an exception
she's so hard-ass she's so obviously
beautiful but also so hard-ass that
there's this there's this you know when
she's around you you want to like mock
Obamacare you want to start making fun
of it like you're right specific jokes
just too many roles yeah just get in is
to get in there just again and spill
talk to her
yeah Santa's white you're goddamn right
II know she's white VRC show me one
picture with Santa black that wasn't
drawn by a black guy